next is going to be DJ in California hi
DJ how are you I did thank you for
having me on the show I listen every day
thank you how can we help so I'm single
28 years old finished college with a
degree in business admin node that I got
20k and a money market savings from my
emergency fund making about 40k year on
my own small businesses video editor in
LA and I love what I do but financial
piece is becoming a priority as I get
older coronavirus has flowed to the
business to to healthcare clients and my
question is what do I need to do to get
on track to become an everyday
millionaire is that new career time or
do I hold tight and keep doing what I
love ah well I it sounds like you need
more customers if you're gonna keep
doing what you love mmm so maybe it's
just a marketing issue it's just it's
worrisome as you get older you know I'm
approaching 30 and I only have 20 K in
my account and I'm hearing all these
people on your show you know some of
these getting jobs that are making 90
okay we're under Katie Orr it's great to
have your own small business and you can
go to PV where a few days to your job
every day but you know it also comes
time though and maybe anything get a job
to a corporation or something it could
be to be you move in as a staff editor I
mean what what city do you live in in
California
I don't I'm not longer very expensive
place to live - and you're only making
40 right yes and actually I've been able
to reach that because one of my clients
is actually letting me stay at their
Studios like nighttime security so I
don't have that obviously the other
house
so I pocket everything I make and that's
an exchange for cheaper audits for that
client but then again we come back to
I'm only making 40k a year and this is
about seven years into my business yeah
yeah what I would do is to say Henry
cloud has a book out called necessary
endings and he says when you lose hope
that there's no logical reason to
believe anymore that something is going
to get better
relationship a job a business a there's
no logical reason that you can extend
out in the future and you lose hope that
it's gonna get better it's time for a
necessary ending and so you could be
approaching that here but what I would
do is I would want to paint myself into
a corner and prove that if I were you
meaning you say all right I'm gonna give
myself six months and I need to be from
forty to sixty and six months after that
I need to be from sixty to eighty or
whatever the number is and if I'm not
I'm gonna shut this thing down and go
get a job okay or something give
yourself some deadlines to meet
so you don't stay in status quo and
pushes yourself along I'm saying DJ go
out swinging if you watch a championship
UFC fight in round five when when the
corner knows that there's one round left
and they're guys down on the cards
they'll always tell them don't leave
anything to the judges like you're
already good we already know you're
gonna lose the fight if it ends right
now so go down swing and so if you have
reservations about going to get new
clients if you're nervous about making
cold calls throw all that to the wind
hustle hustle give yourself an
opportunity to really knock this out of
the park for the next six months and
then you can know you can put a period
at the end of this sentence my brother
does digital editing for a company I see
some there are artists that work here at
Ramsey solutions that are digital uh
that do digital stuff with with the
video editing they're artists are
incredible so there are is places where
you can make a good living but give it
to yourself into the seven years you've
put into this to go down swinging yeah
just you know I'll leave it all on the
field so that's a good point and try
everything pull out all the stops and
sometimes if you give yourself that
deadline and you say something
reasonable what's a reasonable growth
rate on this business that would make me
believe because of the trajectory that's
staying in it is good and I just made
those numbers up I don't know if they're
good or not but if you said okay six
months from now I got to be at sixty I'm
at forty now what have I got to do to
make what has to be true that's not true
now to make that happen I got a call uh
more people I got a turnover more rocks
so something runs out I got to stretch
it out I gotta leave it all on the field
go down swinging like John saying let's
call on a whole bunch of people so
whatever your
number of prospecting calls were they
probably need to go up 10 to 10 to 100 X
because you may have been doing one
mm-hmm and so you know me talking to a
hundred instead of one and you just need
to you know like you said it's a
marketing problem you brought that up DJ
and so that may be exactly where you